up or down up or down up and down okay
focus meeting sorry I just hot room to
hell alright so yeah we know some stuff
that's why I hate yourself IQ much ah
I'm offending so many people in this
video alright something wrong mean fat
but she looks like she looks like a
[ __ ] marshmallow what is - what is
this what is that give me that
Dale oh oh it's your always one of the
party dillos I just heard a rush you put
them in and they're like wow ladies
calling animal oh it's a flashlight well
it's easy to get those mixed up makes
sense now okay Shay maybe she didn't but
whatever alright just go on oh no kitty
cats [ __ ] um you were in the shower
room right the black page I knew it you
have some sort of speaking disease maybe
a brain tumor
hello wait EMTs radio Dean we have a
patient on the way make preparations on
the first floor all right dr. shalba
chickening army writing haha stupid I
need to go to the first floor but how do
I get Oh
mommy when are you coming to visit I'm
not your mom girl you called it all
number okay I'll be a good girl I won't
complain about the care yeah don't
complain about [ __ ] guys waiting for
you no I'm not coming don't wait for me
back okay I told you I'm not coming come
here I told you I doubt God girl never
listen such a final happy I mean he's a
dinosaur or you see I was wondering what
the [ __ ] dashi
maybe I found herself a [ __ ]
how's it going bros my name is beautifu
hope you enjoyed this calling montage if
you did why not give it a like and add
it to your favorite it would really help
me out a lot
I only finished the first part of these
games if you want to see the second part
be sure that you are subscribed up above
and join the bro army today are you too
scared
it's the scared man
anyway also be sure to leave a comment
telling me which of these moments were
your favorite or comment about whatever
you want and that's pretty much it it
comes
you